i wanted to believe that tristan could
change i wanted to trust him i'm so
anxious
what chloe how do you when did you faint
it's a shocking reveal khloe kardashian
says she passed out after finding out
tristan thompson cheated again and has a
baby on the way isn't that crazy
it all starts when cameraman raced to
film kim kardashian in the gym on the
hulu show moments after she's the first
to find out about tristan's secret
paternity lawsuit it's his whole thing
saying i'm tristan thompson met this
girl in houston i slept with her on my
30th birthday so i sent it to him and i
said does chloe know about this chloe
doesn't even
since kim can't reach chloe she calls
her sisters kylie and court in
[Music]
no she's not awake and what's so crazy
is
he wrote a whole declaration
no i know safe to say chloe's sisters
are fed up and fuming over tristan's
behavior the whole thing that's so sad
is she wants a baby boy and [ __ ] now
this girl's having a baby boy random
that he sleeps with one night
him oh i was so team him she doesn't
deserve that she doesn't deserve this
and it gets worse the news drops with
two shocking revelations the baby is
coming fast
today yes today is the date chloe threw
him his 30th birthday so she he went
home from the 30th birthday party went
to houston to play on the road we can
check his schedule and then slept with
this girl
the woman accusing tristan of fathering
her son marilee nichols a fitness model
who gave birth and later confirmed
through a dna test that it is in fact
tristan's child and the nba star has a
history of being unfaithful in 2019 he
was accused of kissing kylie's then bff
jordan woods things happen and of course
i'm sorry and apologetic as much as i
can be he also cheated on chloe when she
was pregnant with their now
four-year-old daughter true i was nine
months pregnant
when you cheated on me
and if you if i wasn't pregnant i would
have picked you up so i just didn't want
to break my nails before delivery
shout out to the nails yeah for sure
and as a result coco and tristan have
been on and off for years in the
kardashians premiere they're
co-parenting but not romantically
involved tristan and i currently are
not
exactly together
he's a really hands-on dad and me and
tristan don't have tension we get along
really really well
and so it's just easy to co-parent with
him
but before this latest scandal it seems
tristan and chloe were on the right
track raising their little girl it's
hard work for all parties i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style and as hard as it is to watch
chloe admits to her mom kris jenner she
saw a change in tristan right before
news of the scandal broke all tristan
talks to me about sometimes is getting
married yeah he talks about it all the
time but i'm like
he's always talking about how much he
wants to make sure that he regains that
trust that he knows that he lost i'm not
with tristan to just float around with
tristan i mean marriage is the end goal
but right now i still think there's
just work to be done with him and i both
regardless of her relationship status
one thing's for sure coco always keeps
it real is there anything you won't show
or are there no boundaries um i think
for every sister we have different
boundary levels and we all try to
respect that what is in the media is
sort of things that we feel we need to
film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives
[Music]
you